so I think you and I eat some more diets
at least I was the first time I've heard
this yeah so I was doing it first time
anyone has said that to me yeah but it's
becoming more and more cool and but I
was doing it before was cool
so the intermittent fasting and fasting
in general I really enjoy I love food
but I enjoy the the I also love
suffering because I'm Russian so fasting
kind of makes you appreciate makes you
appreciate what it is to be human
somehow so but I have a outside the
philosophical stuff I have a more
specific question it also helps me as a
programmer and a deep thinker like
stifling that from a scientific
perspective to sit there for many hours
and focus deeply maybe you were a hacker
before you were CEO what have you
learned about diet lifestyle mindset
that helps you maximize mental
performance to be able to focus for
death think deeply in this world of
distractions I think I just took it for
granted for too long which aspect just a
social structure of we eat three meals a
day and there's snacks in between and I
just never really asked the question why
oh by the way in case people don't know
I think a lot of people know who you you
at least do famously eat once a day yeah
you still eat once a day
yep hey are you nur by the way what made
you decide to eat once a day like this
to me that was a huge revolution that
you don't have to eat breakfast that was
like I felt like I was a rebel like I
yeah like abandon my parents or
something because in a darkest when you
when you first like the first week you
start doing it feels you kind of like
have a superpower yeah then you realize
it's not really a superpower but it I
think you realize at least I realized
like it just how much is how much our
mind dictates what we're possible of and
and sometimes we have structures around
us the incentivize like you know this
3mm a day thing which was purely social
structure verse
is necessity for our health and for our
bodies and I I did it just I I started
doing it because I played a lot with my
diet when I was a kid and I was vegan
for two years and just went all over the
place
just because I you know a health is the
most precious thing we have and none of
us really understand it so being able to
ask the question through experiments
that I can perform on myself and learn
about I is compelling to me and I heard
this one guy on a podcast wim HOF who's
famous for doing ice baths and holding
his breath and all these things he said
he only eats one meal a day I'm like wow
that sounds super challenging and
comfortable I'm gonna do it so I I just
I learned the most when I make myself I
want to say suffer but when I make
myself feel uncomfortable because
everything comes to bear in those
moments and and you really learn what
your what you're about or what you're
not so I been doing that my whole life
like when I was a kid I could not like I
was I could not speak like I had to go
to speech therapists and it made me
extremely shy and then one day I
realized I can't keep doing this and I
signed up for the for the speech Club
and you know it was a the most
uncomfortable thing I could imagine
doing getting a topic on a note card
having five minutes to write a speech
about whatever that topic is not being
able to use the note card while speaking
and speaking for five minutes about that
topic so but it just it puts so much it
gave me so much perspective around the
power of communication around my own
deficiencies and around if I set my mind
to do something I'll do it so it gave me
a lot more confidence so I see fasting
in the same light this is something that
was interesting challenging
uncomfortable
and has given me so much learning and
benefit as a result and it will lead to
other things that I experiment with and
play with but um yeah it does feel a
little bit like a superpower sometimes
the most boring superpower one can
imagine now it's quite incredible the
clarity of mind is it's pretty
interesting
you